hi there Steve here so this morning is
going to be sort of a longer video for
those of you who have the patience
I hope it's useful some of you may not
want to watch it I'm talking again about
you know getting into a new language
which for me now is Turkish and I'm
showing you what I do some people seem
to not like the fact that I refer to
link but that's in fact where I learn so
it's gonna be about link and I've been
at it for five or six days then I'm
gonna show you the sort of state of my
progress and some of the things that I
do it's a good 15 minutes using loom
that enables me to get on to the web
version and also of a link and also I
can connect my ipod and show you what I
do on the excuse me the iPad what I do
on a mobile device it's kind of a part
of my activity the biggest part of what
I do is listening as you'll see what I
think is important is to learn a
language and I think what separates sort
of successful or experienced language
learners from less successful or less
experienced language learners is our
willingness us us the sort of language
learners our willingness to accept
uncertainty things that we don't
understand and to still continue
confident that even as we're getting all
kinds of words dumped on us and as we're
trying to read things that we don't
understand and we don't know how the
conjugation works and we don't know a
number of rules of grammar and so
there's all kinds of stuff that's
uncertain but as long as we just plow
forward like we're swimming in this
stuff right the weather the breast
stroke or the crawl and it's all kind of
washing over us and while we think we're
not learning anything in fact our brain
is slowly starting to get accustomed to
it and so that's what you're gonna see
that I'm exposing myself to these
stories in Turkish and I listen for the
tenth twelve fifteenth time and I don't
understand and I read and listen and I
understand a little better and then I
listen again and I don't understand
and I know that there's all kinds of
Turkish grammar and people talk about it
on the Internet
suffixes and stuff like that but I don't
even want to know about those things I
just want to get a sense of how the
language works where I can actually
start to make some meaning of what I am
reading and listening to that's all I
want to achieve and I know from
experience that if I persevere in that
if I keep doing that slowly the fog
lifts slowly the brain starts to see
certain structures certain patterns
certain words as natural as having
meaning and as that starts to happen you
start to gain a toehold the jigsaw
puzzle starts to have a few pieces that
make the other pieces start to become
clearer so we have to accept uncertainty
and for quite a long time because we're
constantly challenging ourselves to go
into more difficult content where there
are more new words and again it's it's
uncertain and on Twitter I saw this
teacher saying you know a comprehensible
input but how do you know for sure that
your students understood and you need to
ask them even if you ask them in their
own language and and of course my point
of view in all of this is it doesn't
matter if I understand it doesn't matter
if I understand incorrectly and I quote
the famous Brazilian educator ruim Alves
who says nothing
you know disturbs the enjoyment of
reading as much as being asked questions
about what we have read it's not
necessary I can plow forward
misunderstanding not understanding it
doesn't matter as long as I have the the
willingness to accept uncertainty and as
long as I keep going eventually the fog
will lift and that's a great feeling and
that as I say is in that first
three-month period as we take something
that's totally unfamiliar to us strange
just so much noise and at the end of
that three-month period we are now at
least familiar with the language to some
extent and then we have another long
long road to go okay then and
hope you enjoy this video the
demonstration of how I work both on the
browser and in my iPad bye for now so
here I am using loom and I'm doing
something I haven't done before I'm
going to demonstrate what I do on the
web version the browser version and what
I do on my iPad which I have connected
to my computer and hope I'll be able to
demonstrate um we're talking about as I
said we're talking about a new language
how do we get traction in a new language
how can we expect to progress in a new
language and I'm gonna show you what I
do in the case of Turkish now every
language is different Turkish for me has
very few cognates or words that I know
from other languages although there are
some from European languages some from
Arabic and Persian which of course help
when I find them
okay so I have poked around the library
a little bit but most of my learning is
around these many stories I started
Turkish so the first thing is so when
did I start Turkish it's it's kind of
useful to remember if you're dealing
with a new language when did you
actually start and how much have you
been doing so for those of you who are
on link you can go to your picture and
if you look at the picture there's a
number of things that are available
there are people very often don't
realize they can change their settings
the dictionary language or other
settings they can look at their profile
which I'm going to do but they can also
look at the academy or the help areas in
order to see explanations and videos on
how to get more out of link but I wanted
to show you here the profile because
that's where I get a quick snapshot of
when I started and what I've been doing
we noticed by the way that I have a
hundred and eighty-nine known words in
Turkish that I've been creating far more
links here if you can see this then then
my goal I have a six-day streak so I
guess I've been going six days
and if we look at this we will see that
this is known words let's start with my
major activity really is initially is
listening so let's go to listening let's
think for the last seven days so we see
that I started I started on the fifth of
June and I listened half an hour I took
it up to a little over an hour back down
to 40% of an hour whatever that is 25
minutes when had a big day here I must
have been jogging or cleaning up around
the house and so this is my listening so
I have a total of you know in 6 days
I've got 6 hours so I'm listening about
an hour a day and that typically
triggers my reading because after I
listen I can't understand and so here
again you'll see that the reading
significantly increased and drop down
one of the things with reading is that
the system automatically tracks when you
read something for the first time
because the blue words are converted to
you know yellow or known words it
doesn't track automatically the second
or third time you read but of course I
do read the same story quite a few times
because I don't understand it even after
reading it two or three times so that
you have to manually add alright so make
sure you do that I think I started
manually adding in the times that I read
a story for the second or the third time
you know I could go on with this you
know the number of links you know
created for example and here again that
shows you know my daily activity some
days I'd create as many as 446 links
this typically will mean that I rented
new material if I'm reviewing old
material than I'm not creating so many
links so I just mentioned that to you as
as a place that you can go to regularly
just to see you know when you started
when you've been active and things of
that nature
alright before I leave
you know one thing I have thought of is
you know one thing that Constantine in
Kiev with his russian-speaking audience
does he has his learner's share their
daily statistics with other members of
the group so for example yesterday this
is what I did yesterday
somehow he does it on telegram I don't
know if people have any ideas on a quick
way people share what they did they ask
each other questions people who are
learning the same language anyway now
I'm gonna see if I can get on to my iPad
so hopefully this works
so I'm in my many stories let's see that
it opens up very good now I I'm not sure
that I can know you'll have to follow
the cursor you see here play course
audio if I click there I will have the
whole 60 stories of the audio will be
available to listen to in a playlist
although you can define that if I don't
yeah well also if I do that play course
audio so you can then choose here
whether whether you want to look at all
of the listen to all the audio like all
60 lessons one after the other or just
the ones that you have completed or just
the ones that you have opened so this
way if I've only say completed ten
stories then it'll loop back and just do
the first ten stories also it's worth
noticing noticing that you can you know
with each story you can choose to go
over and over again or just continue the
next story now let's go back here for a
second
if we go through these stories you'll
see that because there's a solid green
line there these are all the stories
where I have gone through once and
created links in other words you know I
see all these blue words and I've sort
of take off the cover so to speak to see
what's there
and I find that if I if I let's go back
for a second to the playlist so we'll
see on the playlist that you know story
while I listen to 25 times I still don't
understand the same part lesson 2 lesson
3 and I don't listen to the message I
may sometimes less than 2 or 3 times to
the same story typically I'll do that if
I have the story open on my iPad and I
just have it repeating repeating and
repeating and then I go and read the
story and then I listen again or if I'm
listening on my on my iPhone or my ipod
touch then typically I'm going Story 1 2
3 4 5 and then it loops back to Story 1
again
however despite having listened to these
stories so many times they're still
relatively unclear to me now that's not
surprising it's been my experience if
however I go to a story let's say Story
6 here and if I can start to get to the
story I can either slide and open it or
I can touch the big you know 6 sofa
either way if I touch the big 6 number
it'll open up the story now if I listen
to the story which I can't do because if
the sound won't come through with loom
here but if I listen to the story and
read at the same time I kind of more or
less understand it you know if there's
words there that I can
yom-yom a Yeller is to eat action action
eat dinner
Baba together side yet in a 7 o'clock
Aksum yummy yummy Yeller oh yah oh yah
oh you love it
oh yeah Lana is their child oh la la la
villita yeah Makia so they eat together
with them the child son eats together
with them yeah if I if I have the
opportunity to read it and listen to it
I understand it once I go away and I
don't have the help of being able to
read it I have a lot of trouble
understanding it however I know from
experience that in time this will
proof now when I read something for the
third or fourth time by the way just to
show you if I click on the three dots at
the top then I read that says four times
I can add one time okay that's not true
yet but that's where you have to add in
manually when you read the story for the
however many time so I can look at the
course here and just to show you what
happened because after a while when I
read the story for the third fourth
fifth time we have to remember that
anything we do for the third fourth
fifth time we're getting less out of it
it is repetition but there's less
novelty less freshness and I find that
we start to get stale so I very you know
I'll alternate going over the same old
stories with going to new stuff so I can
go up to story 21 for example and oh
I've done story 21 so again I can hit
the top dots there and just simply go
next let's see what story 22 looks like
so starting 22 has blue words so that's
great so and and I see some words like
doctor of course I can tell from English
dr. Isles to the doctor he then I know
that verbs that contain did and I'm not
some yeah didn't is to go so this is a
story about a meanie who goes to the
doctor okay
I mean a Ken Denis Ken Denis can delay I
don't know what Ken Denis is I have to
look it up or himself up Kent in your
head II and I was good and he said me or
like he said the or is to feel I know
that I remember that vaguely and me is
is no not so you know I look it up he
sent me or so I kind of still keep that
as a yellow word but I enjoy uncovering
the blue word so Bashi / not clear what
that means head out of your audio hurts
okay she's got a headache audio and
they are noise and Bazzi Wazza Wazza
throat Bozza hd60 sore i presume that it
says swell but then if i save that
together it probably says sore throat
throat swish that's not very good that's
kind of a bad so if I go to my
dictionary and let's go to see what this
dictionary tells us swollen throat
alright
maybe sorry I'll call that a sore throat
that's maybe I should also point out
that these are the dictionaries that I
have here any dictionary that doesn't
give me good answers I don't use but I
find this essentially shows look is
quite good one thing to show you for
example Turkish suffix suffixes are a
big deal in Turkish so this dictionary
shows you a complete list of all the
different suffixes so you know if I pick
that one you know but there is no way
that I can remember all of this this is
just a reference area if I ever have a
question about suffixes I just go there
and so it's kind of handy to have that
without pretending that we can learn
that all right same with the verb
conjugator z' here's a verb conjugator
I'll have to go to find the Turkish
where did you go Turkish so you know and
I know some of these verbs like get met
you know ya MEK to eat submit to like
but if I click on one of them I see this
tremendous range of verbs tremendous
range of verbs obviously there is no way
you know if I were to confront that
without having been exposed to a lot of
the language I would be totally
intimidated so I ignore that I just know
that it's there it's a reference that I
can go to my main task right now and
this is what I want to leave you with is
I want to at this stage 5 days into the
language I want to expose myself to the
language I can do this either by going
over material that I have
ready read listen to 20 times read five
times or alternate that with moving
forward and reading new stories and in
the new stories there will be words that
I've seen before for example this cut
out of idiot
cut out video is to decide I know that
cut out of it cut out of it I come
across it before decides so you'll come
across some words that you've seen
before and you'll uncover some new words
and so I'm not worried about remembering
them but I just want to provide some
variety so that I'm not kind of
constantly going over the same material
that I'm varying new material with
trying to get better at recognizing old
material five days in I'm at lesson 22
in terms of uncovering new material and
you know at the end of month one I I
think I'll be able to understand the
first twenty lessons and the month to
the first forty and month three I'll
have sixty and by that time then I will
be at the end of what I consider the
first stage in language learning and
that is for the language no longer to
seem strange but for the language to
seem you know at least familiar so that
you can then expand from there back to
let's see what happens if i press this
okay expand from that and and and then
start to accumulate a lot of vocabulary
so that you can actually get comfortable
on the language so that is now i will
try and shut this thing down somehow
i hope that was useful helpful if you
have any questions about anything that
you saw there or any other questions
about language learning about link
please don't hesitate to ask me and
remember don't worry about what you
understand give yourself credit for what
you have already achieved and when you
look back and think about it you'll
realize that you have actually come a
long way
okay bye for now
you